i'm thinking now my mind's flashing too
the night
argo wins uh best picture
of the year michelle obama and jack
nicholson present to you
the academy award
man now i'm starting to realize what a
triumph that was for you i mean what an
emotional moment better than the first
oscar for good will hunting this was
your [ __ ] you hey i'm back and you know
what i'm better than ever what a moment
it was it was the you're right i'm not
ally that was the single most sort of
self-satisfying moment because for so
long i just felt like i gotta prove i
belong here i gotta i can't be a [ __ ]
i gotta show these people i gotta tell
these people you know i gotta prove it i
gotta prove it
i mean something i'm worth something i
and and years 15 years after google
hunting
and a lot of years you know in the
[ __ ] and a lot of [ __ ]
and [ __ ]
and then
and i think we were going to win but
i'll tell you you're right it was much
more meaningful
because it wasn't and it wasn't even
[ __ ] you i remember saying like
i i i mean i i that speech is like a
little bit like uh incoherent in my
memory but i do remember saying for some
reason like i was so much to myself you
can't hold grudges because i knew that
if i had held on to that bitterness i
wouldn't have got there and that you
know i was happy
and i and i felt like okay
to have enough
enough
you gotta let me [ __ ] are you gonna
at least say i don't you can say i hate
my movies
but can you at least
do me the courtesy of reflecting fairly
back to me all right you belong here
fine fine
it's fabulous and i don't know how
important these awards are to you but i
sense that it is important and it's your
peers saying you're great
uh but you know it was weird that you
weren't nominated as best director for
that that was the thing i got it was the
big snub right yeah and that was really
taught me a lot because you know i did
everything they told me gotta kiss the
babies and i schmoozed every [ __ ]
buddy in the world right part of us
because you're the director and you want
to do it but the truth is part of it's
because i wanted it
i wanted it and you're like most people
i think if they say they don't are
probably not totally honest i wanted it
and i wanted it for that reason
and then and everybody told me you're
gonna oh you're gonna win it wasn't
you're gonna be nominated you're the lie
you're the nuts you're gonna win you're
a lock
and so of course did i get up
that morning go sit in front of the tv
and i i i did assume i was gonna get
nominated you know why because everybody
said it so what do you think if all
these people they must know
and
they read those names and i remember
thinking like
it's never gonna end
i'm never gonna get it like no one's
ever gonna be willing to just say okay
yeah it was good
and and i had done everything and so i
first thing i did was i called up the
warner brothers people who worked really
hard who really wanted it for me
you know and i said guys i think you
know i'm done
no more baby i'm never going to do it
again no right ass kissing no
handshaking i don't give a [ __ ] they
don't want to give it okay and maybe i
don't deserve it if the directors didn't
think i deserve it that's their opinion
and that's fine you know they think that
i'm proud of the movie i'm glad you know
billy got nominated and chris got
nominated and they're like oh we got
picture and i was like yeah we got a
picture
but they made sure to leave me out
um well it's almost ludicrous to have
the best picture of the year and the
director didn't get an award it doesn't
even compute that's not always one of
those things like we had editor score
screenplay uh picture you know like whoa
i was the only guy who [ __ ] up was the
lead and the director i i can do the
math on who the [ __ ] is here and that
day i had to go to the [ __ ] critics
choice awards
which has as many if my memory is
correct the single longest [ __ ] red
carpet in humanity and every single stop
there's pretty they didn't have to say
anything this whole to make it just so
snubbed
you know when you gotta pretend that
you're okay and pretend it didn't bother
you because god forbid something bother
you i went in to the you know critics
choice you know got hammered the table
figure but we're [ __ ]
and
then we [ __ ] win
and i was like we won we won the critics
choice well there you go and so i went
up and said you know why i want to thank
the academy because i just didn't give a
[ __ ] anymore and then of course like it
happens all the time in life we never
lost another award
maybe we want all the every other
meeting and they got plenty of them you
know like does anything need that many
awards like do we have we got one nobel
peace prize and 40 movie awards
so you know it was it was a big deal but
i also at that point i thought okay i am
glad with one picture obviously it meant
something to me
but i was like i'm not gonna make this
my metric anymore i'm just gonna be like
i wanna stand out to do this if i do it
i'll feel good